[Music]
well the plan to break California off
from the rest of the United States is
back with an interesting new twist the
leaders of cal exit have announced a new
version of their scheme to create an
independent California in this all
federal lands in the state that which is
about half of all of California will be
returned to American Indian tribes
creating quote the first-ever autonomous
Native American nation in North America
organizers say this country would
provide a buffer zone between the
California Republic and Trump's America
Marcus Ruiz Evans is co-founder of Cal
exit and always game enough to come on
our show we appreciate that he joins us
tonight from Fresno Marcus thanks all
for coming on so Tucker thanks for
having me back on again and I came
prepared oh I brought you your shirt
I'll ship it to you after the show I
love it I will wear that ironically of
course
so I'm but I'm looking at this plan and
I notice that the Indians are getting
the inland parts the eastern parts of
California and everybody else is getting
the choice real estate where the
majority of the state's population lived
if you really wanted to atone for an
historic sins why wouldn't you give the
Indians Santa Monica Lihua right Napa
why not do that good point that's a
great point you're totally right yeah
you know the best thing to do for a
Native American people would be to give
them back all of the land and everybody
who's not needed leave and then petition
to become an immigrant and then native
people could choose who they wanted to
come back in obviously that's not going
to happen so what we did at Cal exit was
say what's the best thing that we could
do that's not going to fix genocide
isn't going to fix everything not make
it all perfect but what's the biggest
leap that we could make in the right
direction and we felt that giving over
half of California and basically the
American control part to Native people
who actually owned the land would at
least be a step in the right direction
and I want to point out now you're
basing this ask you know I know this is
all it's California you know what I mean
like you'll figure it out it's a work in
progress but is there a specific Indian
Reservation that you think is a kind of
model for good governance that you're
basing this on can you point to a
reservation
currently in the United States and say
we want California to be more like that
no well first we don't call them Indians
we call them natives or indigenous
second we don't call it a reservation a
lot of Indians call themselves Indians
we'll just so you know okay
I I'm not trying to debate I'm just
saying how we and calotype
it's definitely not a reservation and to
answer your question we're doing it as
not a reservation because there is no
good model of a reservation reservations
are a failed system at Farpoint Harkins
I Gregg up for the genocide that they
caused against Native people I agree
with that actually words magazine
pointed this out no no I mean here it's
demonstrable true the reservations are a
disaster for the people who live on them
now I totally agree that are you worried
though that this could be open to
exploitation I mean what would prevent
Elizabeth Warren from coming in as an
Indian and saying I'm now the king of
this new country and would there be some
test to make sure that you really are an
Indian before you take possession of
half of California so I want to point
out what I said was that reservations
aren't working out because of America
America doesn't right let native people
own their land they're not able to take
profits from it the FBI can go and
harass them any time the schools
provided for them are horrible the court
system provided for them is horrible and
they don't even have the ability to
protect their own drinking water as we
saw with the protests recently to answer
your question specifically Elizabeth
Warren would not be able to come in
there unless the native people of that
area said that she's welcome so if they
isn't native well that market is native
one person which is they're called and
yes she could but if they didn't do that
it doesn't matter what she says she
wouldn't be allowed in okay well I think
I'm now you're winning me over now I
just want to know how this works so the
idea is this is atonement for things
that happened a long time ago so if one
of my ancestors had something stolen
from him a hundred and fifty years ago
does that mean that the descendants of
the person who stole it
Oh me the money with interest if I can
find them
this is under your so that's a system of
justice yeah it is so not in an
individual either a level so if your
grandfather did something racist and
horrible
you shouldn't be punished for that
however you did benefit from it but it's
a mistake to go after you as a person so
what we're saying is that the people and
the government representing the people
should make amendments so we're not
saying we're picking on individuals
we're saying the government of
California millions of people live in
this area
you were almost out of time but what's
what's going to happen to the millions
people who live in this Indian country
like you aren't Indian well the primary
Trump voters who live in that area will
have to do what brown skinned people
tell them to do because brown skinned
people will be in charge and if they
don't like that they're welcome to leave
California Wow
reeducation camps I knew it was gonna
get to this Marcus what I love about you
is your honesty we're out of time nine
seconds left I have a Caesar night thank
you I know you are I love that Thank You
Tucker